اعلى نتايه الاعلام المرئي والمسموع
للاسبوع الثاني على التوالي عن تصدر
الفيلم السعودي سطار لقائمه الافلام
الاكثر اقبالا على الشباك السعودي من حيث
المبيعات طبعا وذلك من خلال اقل من
اسبوعين فقط من انطلاقه حيث قاربت مبيعات
الفيلم حتى الان المئتين الف التذكره
ليصبح بذلك اسرع فيلم سعودي يفعل ذلك عن
الاطلاق
في قالبه هو بطلنا سعد بطوله ابراهيم
الحجاج يتعرض الى شويه زي ما يقولون تنمر
من المجتمع لان يحب المصارعه الحره تعرف
على عبد العزيز الشهري علي هوجن يبي طبيعه
الحال اخذه في منحنى اخر وداخله في
المصارعه الحره وهذا الشيء ودي اقول لك
عنه احنا واحنا نكتب الفيلم كده نبحث عن
همم مصارعه حقيقيه عشان نضبط تمثيلها
ونضبط الاكشن فيها اخذنا ابراهيم الحجاج
في جوله طويله تقريبا اربع شهور
دربنا
وخليناه يتقن كيف المصارعين يدخل كيف
المصارعين يحمس الجمهور كيف المصارعيه
يحتفل زرناهم في اس بي دبليو في عروضهم
خاصه شاف بعينه وشلون الدنيا صايره وشلون
قعدت تتحرك
لو سمحت
صوتهم تماما في عمل همم في المسطار كحك
همم كوميديه رائعه جدا القصه مناسبه جدا
للطرح همم
نعم الشخصيه الارتكازيه لابراهيم الحجاج
لعبه الدور بشكل متففاني ولكن اتمنى انه
لا تتكرر الشخصيه كثيرا حتى لا ياسر
الفنان نفسه همم داخل الشخصيه
مكان افاتار اللي يتصدر قوائم الشباك
السينمائي في كل دول العالم ما عدا
السعوديه وهي سابقه كمان تحدث جماهيريا
للمره الاولى
جدا في قاعه السينما بشكل عام همم المتعه
موجوده من بدايه الفيلم نهايه الفيلم
الكوميديا متصله طبعا اضاف عبد الله همم
عبد العزيز الشهري همم كانت الاضافه
الرائعه في العمل حقيقه بشكل عام وهي
الشخصيه الجميله المسانده ايضا لابراهيم
الحجاج
اصداء جميله على موضوع القبول وهذا اهم
شيء ان الواحد يحثر الفيلم ويقول لك والله
هذا الشيء يشبهنا والله هذه النكته سعوديه
هذا الشيء كان فعلا قد شفته امس كنت شفته
قبل امس كنت شفتها قبل فتره فعلا هذا شيء
شفناه في ملاحقنا شفناه في مجتمعنا شفناه
في شارعنا احنا يعني شفت عائله راحت شفت
اصدقاء اخذوا بعض راحوا بس ان في مدرسه
تقول انا اخذت طلابي ورحنا مع بعض تفرجنا
هذا الشيء لاول مره اشوفه الفيلم احنا
حرصنا انه يكون لونها لون سعودي حرصنا انه
يحاكي الشارع حرصنا ان نحط فيه البوم
مصاحب للفيلم راح ينزل بعد يومين كنا نبحث
عن هذه الاغنيه بالصدفه لقينا فريق العمل
همم شاف بوست من شباب الرانده اليوم
الرانده كان حاطط البوست انه بعد يومين
بتنزل هذا الاغنيه وحطه منها خمس ثواني
فورا فريق العمل تواصل معهم قالوا لهم هل
ينفع هذه الاغنيه تكون حصريه اللي في فيلم
صبار هذه موجوده في الفيلم فهي دخلت
الفيلم الاخير
ماشيه في الفيلم هتنزل في الالبوم قريب
من دبج عادي